Now welcome um
here in um Oberhof to the faction retreat of the
um AfD Bundestag faction.
We have prepared 1 position paper,
that we would like to have him come later.
And um,
we will simply present a few key points to them now,
how we can encounter this Germany-wide misery.
Because um,
maybe once to the basic,
one has the feeling in the meantime,
that this government will not be quick enough
uh can go,
flatten this land and drive in front of the wall.
There are
completely insane um law uh law project
on the way.
And um,
we see from this government
no solution prospects at all.
Even the CDU device itself asoppositionsverweigerer um
and accordingly
no solution is to be expected there either.
We have made ourselves um the task,
the D
stop Germany's industrialization immediately,
we should be in theRegierungsverantwortung.
The energy costs are clearly too high.
For this reason,
we would immediately collect the EEG.
We would make sure of that,
that an energy policy is pursued responsibly,
the technology is open.
And to this,
of course,
uh belongs to the immediate measure,
the existing nuclear power plants,
that can be switched on - these are the last ones,
that were switched off,
to be put back into operation immediately.
And um,
new nuclear power plants
even with newer technologies um
to build keyword torium,
Reactor et cetera PP,
all this will not
made um Germany um relies on
Flutter current,
on um,
the renewable um energies,
as they are called.
They are of course with nieces
the still n single digit um percentage
um of the energy mix.
Here um make out
and uh,
for this completely crazy
green um government it is perfectly fine,
how it is the um
Vice and Minister of Economics and Energy
said,
the children's author Robert Habeck,
that it is perfectly fine,
From Ukraine
ähm electricity also to import.
And um,
that it is perfectly fine for Ukraine um,
that they um their old nuclear power plants
keep going,
because they had been built Oton after all.
That makes me really wonder,
what this
Minister of Economics and Energy actually has in mind.
It switches
the most modern nuclear power plants AB in Germany
and wants other
run highly endangered painters.
So that's the principle first.
We will,
as soon as we are in theRegierungsverantwortung,
turn off.
Because we need a reasonable energy mix
and of course nuclear power
uh which is part of order to avoid these horrendous energy costs
to be switched off and lowered again.
Because we price ourselves out of the market.
The companies today
suffer from these energy costs
and they have to imagine,
that energy costs in the value chain
in every product.
That is why all products become more expensive.
This is rarely understood
connection to this matter,
that this may also be something
have to do with inflation,
with which we are confronted today.
That's why it can only go like this,
to send uh reduce the energy costs
about a reasonable
um um um um energy offer mix.
And um,
we'll do more,
too uh.
We will impose this unspeakable ban on oil and gas heating
we will collect
and immediately.
We will.
Also collect this completely unnecessary,
politically made,
ideologically attached combustion ban.
This combustion ban against he,
that no one is worth it.
That was fairly introduced by the EU
in the last legislature,
when Angela Merkel still had the CDU say that.
She has no objection in the German Bundestag
expressed.
That was only us as the AfD faction.
I recall the vote in 2,018
and also our application,
the burner
or the ban on burners um
harms the German key
Automotive industry asymmetrically high.
It damages our economy
and the high energy costs.
Adding again to this,
Damage to the entire value chain in Germany
and accordingly all companies,
who are active in the production are at risk.
They respond to it.
BSF,
Bayer wacker,
chemistry we see everything
has been in the newspapers for year and day,
that these companies,
which,
by the way,
employers
of hundreds of thousands of people are,
seek the distance.
That is,
these jobs will be cut in Germany,
they are newly emerging abroad.
And who advertises very very large recruitment
Ancestors the People's Republic of China
and at the top before all things
the USA,
which of course absolutely benefits from this
about this insane um
Energy and economic policy,
which is driven here,
we need to reduce costs overall.
The um um,
the uh reaches into tax policy 1
to name only 1 example.
Why um don't we lower property taxes um,
why uh we do not create the CO 2 levy AB?
But you also have to imagine,
right now,
where all the energy costs go through the roof.
And the entire price
for the total population of German companies
comes this excuse.
I just have to say it like this,
this erratic federal government of really
which is so green and left
the FDP should be ashamed of itself in the ground,
that she is the stirrup holder for such a
green left government is,
Who really has nothing else to do,
than destroy this country inrekordgeschwindigkeit
to want.